they've waited so long to cross the
border they can wait a bit longer for
breakfast
hot tea and hunks of bread courtesy of
the belarussian red cross
running the show is the man who last
year as interior minister authorized the
use of force against protesters now he
says he won't force anyone to move
against their will
departure inside a huge logistics center
around a thousand migrants have spent
their first night out of the cold
you can feel the relief and the
exhaustion
and here the holy grail a charging point
a way of plotting their next move
make no mistake for all that the bella
russian authorities are now trying to
build themselves as the good guys this
is a carefully manufactured crisis
payback by alexander lupachenko for
sanctions against his regime and a bid
to impress upon the european union that
he still has cards to play
and he does thousands upon thousands of
them
most people here are determined to keep
trying at the border and they say the
belarusian border guard will help they
told us
why you are stopping here while you are
still here come to we bring you to
another site and we will help you to cut
the border
he doesn't want to go back home and in
the capital minsk we meet many more
migrants and none of them want to go
home either the city streets strewn with
backpacks migrants piling into taxis or
staying put till something changes are
you thinking about other routes we are
we are waiting
just we are waiting for
europe decide
but europe has already decided that it
won't let them in and with so many
thousands still in belarus alexander
lukashenko may find himself with a
bigger problem on his hands than he'd
anticipated
diana magnay sky news in minsk